[Music]  103m escape from the home of mentally  insane adolescence  she is described as an asian female  brown haired brown eye and she is  considered dangerous use extreme caution  copy look at me  hey where your friends are this is  little you alone in this big man world  dude you okay  you don't sound like you're from around  here  i mean  you live in new orleans  i'm not going back there  i don't want to go  [Applause]  she's got no place to stay i'm helping  her out for a little while since when do  you help people hey  she's a little miracle  she's a  fugitive hurt it  if you see this girl do not look in her  eyes  [Music]  why do you think you're in charge  i knew something freaky was gonna happen  tonight it's a full moon i like feel it  in my ovaries i swear to god  [Music]  you